freestyle raps boom
i make up raps on the spot based
entirely on your suggestions all you
guys have to do
think of a word topic phrase you want to
hear a rap about i'll make it happen so
there are some rules okay
don't suggest food don't suggest animals
they're the most obvious things our
brains think of
number three don't be too obvious in
general don't be like i will make it
easy
he's white he's british he can't rap no
make it challenging
some of the best suggestions i ever had
include this one 9th century crop
rotation
so good to put on a hat i had a german
guy in hamburg say a day in the life of
an aztec high priest
so aim for that type of esoteric
creativity
if you have a suggestion give a little
wave in front of your camera we'll
spotlight one of you at random i'll take
a suggestion from you we'll do that four
or five times and then we'll go
so uh i'm not in charge of the spotlight
and someone's going to do it who's it
going to be hey paul what do you want to
hear a rap about
what on a kebab
i mean it violates the food rule twice
but fine you were so enthusiastic
you'd give yourself apple tunnel
syndrome by doing that kumquat
on a kebab brilliant everyone else don't
[ __ ] up like paul okay get on next
it's coming up next what do you want to
hear a rap about uh
architecture etruscan architecture
brilliant that is that is someone who
heard my challenge and was like
yeah mate i'm actually gonna screw him
on this one brilliant etruscan
architecture let's get suggestion number
three who's got it
kylie and ryan hey kylie and ryan what'd
you want to hear a rap about uh
19th century feminist politics 19th
century
feminist politics jesus christ trust a
woman to come up with that
right great thank you very much kylie
brian i feel sorry for you
um let's get two more please what's this
one going to be
hey hey john and not john what do you
want to hear a rap about
bear all jumper a fair isle jumper
brilliant
that's a great suggestion love that
let's get one final suggestion thank you
very much for that
this is the fifth one it's going to be
the best yes it's shaylen and darshner
hey guys what'd you want to hear a rap
about
hey i'd love to hear a wrap about a
chinese leather technician from wuhan
a chinese legislation
leather technician
i mean look i record these wraps i put
them up online this one is definitely
not going up because it's going to be
taken down immediately
okay cool thank you for that guys this
thing lovely people it's a freestyle
wrap that's the wrap made up on the spot
based on those suggestions the
suggestions to remind you kumquat on a
kebab
etruscan architecture 19th century
feminist politics a feral jumper and a
chinese leather technician from wuhan
i'm going to drop that b let's get this
happening made up entirely on the spot
and do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly
toe-curlingly bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle-class white
boy to be
[Music]
paul it's appalling so bad you violate
the rules kumquat and kebab that's 2ks
add 50 percent more the most racist
acronym you ever saw but i'm doing all
the barbecue
it's so ill i spill a bit of oil on the
sides of the grill
get a tiny fruit oh look at that it's
small and it's round it's a tiny kumquat
is that the shape i don't even know in
the tropical fruit aisle i don't go
but a kebab i like to get a little bit
of lamb i grill it nice pink inside i'm
a fancy man and so i don't
understand words said to me by women
from the 19th
century you just added a 10 to the start
of the cap
feminist politics i'll try that yes
it's a period the men want to forget
we'd be fighting for it like a
suffragette technically that's the early
1900s 20th century but i
plundered all the stuff that i've got in
my brain i thirst for names that aren't
just emmeline pankhurst but i ain't got
none so i really can't glow
in my confidence there's no vote but one
lady
she demonstrates the style in the
killing she's so thrilling she'd be
rocking the feral jumper you discover
sarah lunchy on the bridge in norway you
can understand it's knitted on a little
scottish place with all of the wool if
you don't own many then you feel a fool
because
when it gets shivery when it gets cold
it's like a little sheep
is hugging you and holding you with all
the patterns now i be clever let me pull
it all together like i'm stitching
through the leather got a bobbin
got a little bit i can darn it i'm over
in the far east i won't alarm any of
y'all
i'd say this so neat i found a little
pangolin corpse in the street
i'll bring it over here what am i
planning i'm gonna hang it up and dry it
i'll be calling it tanning i'm a man in
wuhan and i'm a technical fool
getting all of the bat as well yes it's
really rule stitch it all together wow
doesn't look
half bad i made a totally cold vid
hangbag
tanning that i'll sell it for a thousand
yen bucks i don't even know
my land is not in the greek area
but i travel far and wide i'm aware of
there i don't need no columns
no corinthian no ionic flute in
i'm a simple man brutalism from the 60s
please
architecture needs olive trees i put my
trust in a trust can i get the architect
asking for a blueprint his plans i
respect
he rolls it out there i say yeah it's
justin i'm busting so
excited for etruscan build it up there
never be a roman get it mediterranean
and i'm showing i know the accuracy
might be slightly out of whack but there
we go that's the first of the freestyle
raps
[Music]
cheers